this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisement you're damn right
they do
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little singing you think that me
every little singing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
hey y'all let's record a podcast I'm
really grateful you're here tonight and
I'm grateful to bring up a guest on the
stage very few people they're very
people like very few people I can say
this about the very few P that I've read
every single one of their books and I
think it's like David Foster Wallace
Mary Karr and our guest tonight I think
this is he just put out his 11th book
and he's one of Time Magazine's 100 most
influential people in the world and
we're really grateful to share this page
with him tonight ladies and gentlemen
rob bell
[Applause]
[Music]
so usually what we do at these podcasts
we take phone calls but don't whip your
phone out and call us up just yet we
have a microphone somewhere Sean do we
know where that where that mic is
somewhere all Matt's telling me did any
of you see our documentary by the way
well if you hated it you can blame Ryan
but if you loved it you can thank the
man who's here on the stage filming a
little bit of this Matt the Avella so
what we usually do is we answer a
handful of questions we'll get some
long-winded answers and we'll move on to
a lightening round but before we do that
and I'm sure Rob will want to
participate the lightning round what we
do is we give like really pithy answers
and we usually have a week to craft
something that's very treatable
but we have like seven seconds now and
so we'll just monitor on a bit until we
get something that is that we can share
with you and you can share on the
Twitter's or or whatever Yik yak
whatever you kids are doing these days
so so Rob you you just put out a new
book and let me let me talk only just
back go back a little bit you put out a
book last year called how to be here and
yeah how'd it be here
one person well she really loved it I'm
I'm hoping there there will be many more
because as this book so I mean everyone
here knows our story if you didn't when
you walked in you do now right I mean
we've caught you up until this moment
basically and my partner Rebecca she you
know she was working for a university
for like a decade and it got to a point
where she didn't necessarily hate it but
she felt like she wasn't doing something
meaningful with her life anymore and she
had at one point but her you know as
life changes she felt like it was time
to graduate from that and I can tell you
that all of my bloviating may have
helped a little but nothing helped more
than Rob's book how to be
here and she decided to walk away from
that last year after reading after
reading how to be here so I want to say
thank you for that I've bought that book
by the case and handed it out to people
either on our podcast at other places as
well so thank you for that and then in
last year you also you put out a audio
book that wasn't a book a project called
launching rockets and I was hoping you
could talk about that a little bit
because quite often we get people who
show up at our events and it you know
the first thing that we hear is like
well you know I'm not yeah I have kids
with all these all of these these
excuses come up and and I found that
that that audio book launching rockets
with you and your wife Kristin it's like
you had these seventeen principles and
then she would sort of correct you at
the end of it and yeah I loved I loved
the format I love the idea especially in
today's sort of podcast world where you
can you can you can put something out
there that is essentially an audio book
but it is not it there's no book that
belongs to it what made you want to do
that because I noticed when I was out
touring and doing questions like you do
how many parents had questions about
their kids and I would say my wife
Christa and I have three kids
19:17 and then we took a two boys that
we took a nine year break and then we
have an eight year old girl with long
blonde hair named violet are you kidding
me who owns me but what's interesting is
somebody would come down with us a mic
right there somebody would come down
they would ask a question it would be
about their kids and you could feel the
anxiety in their question and I would
have the sense like if I'm feeling their
anxiety in their question what's it like
to be that person's kid because your kid
isn't a bucket into which you pour all
your unresolved anxiety fear and worry
about your own life are you with me on
this my wife Kristen when our son was a
sophomore in high school went to a
college prep meeting for for parents of
high school sophomores and high school
sophomores the counselor had to stop the
meeting partway through and call out the
parents for the level of anxiety in the
room we cannot continue unless you all
calm down this is high school sophomores
and that how many people hadn't I just
noticed how many people hadn't done
their own interior work their own fears
worries anxieties things that haunted
them and so their kids was this
wonderfully near receptacle to just
place all of that on so I just begin
with your greatest thing if you're a
parent is not your first job isn't to
raise your kid your first job is to
enjoy them and if you start there it's
just a fundamentally different place and
some kids you know it can be hard to
enjoy so in that moment you have to
double down on fear God give me one
thing today even a tiny little fragment
of a sliver of something good about this
child
because right now I'm barely hanging on
some of you know exactly what I'm
talking about
the rest of you you're about seven years
out but trust me so that's where it
started and then like in the launching
Rockets thing I talked about oh and then
I would also when people ask questions I
would say my kids are still at home so
anybody's kids are still at home should
not be giving parenting advice but I do
have some observations which sort of get
you off the hook then I would just yeah
well okay so when I met Rebecca she had
a one-year-old and so we have a sort of
an unconventional sort of sitcom esque
family now with respect to you know she
has at least three parental figures in
her life and I could tell you that the
anxiety thing was so was so true because
it was so easy from is in it built my
she built my own anxiety which I've been
dumped off on her because I didn't
really have the mechanisms to deal with
the kid at but I met someone that I
loved so much that I'd ovale the way in
headfirst
and and wanted to embrace that and so
thank you for giving me at least a
little bit of a framework there and then
this year you just put out a book and
it's called what is the Bible and now
it's really hard to get me to read a
book about the Bible I mean I grew up
Catholic so we didn't even read the
Bible you didn't even read it the first
time all right why would it be even
building a trusting and Joe like I'm
like now okay well maybe this is the
CliffsNotes but it's not that at all and
and you're going to do such a better job
of explaining it than me and so I am
currently halfway through the book and
one of the things that stood out to me
early on that you never hear has to do
with one of the chapter titles was but
who paid Jesus's bills so who paid
Jesus's bills did we just go from
parenting to who pay Jesus bills I can't
wait for the third question well well
let me back up and say what I just
observed is how many people have no idea
what's in the Bible so if you're like
are we seriously gonna talk about the
Bible right now hold on a second what I
noticed is how many people had no idea
what's in the Bible as particularly
conservative Christians who claimed they
were the ones who were the most faithful
to it actually had nothing new next to
nothing about it so let me just back up
and say the Bible was written by a small
minority group of people who had been
conquered by one global military
superpower after another so this small
group of Jewish people had been
conquered by Egyptians by Persians by
Babylonians by the New Testament it's
the Romans one massive military after
another had marched in and taken over so
if you are the citizen of the most
powerful global military superpower the
world human civilization has ever
created if you're an American you are 5%
of the world's population living in a
country with about 43 percent of it of
the world's weapons how many military
bases is Russia have outside of Russia
eight France seven does England have six
military bases outside
England how many military bases is the
US have outside of the US 660 so it's
really the Pentagon a couple of years
ago spent a billion dollars on
advertising and as we all know
advertising so by the way who spent that
billion dollars on advertising so if you
read an ancient book this is deeply
critical and suspicious of global
military superpowers and you're a
citizen of one there's a chance you
might miss some of its central themes
because when it talks about care for the
poor when it talks about peacemaking
when it talks about the widow the orphan
and the immigrant you might if the
system works for you miss the fact that
this book is by people for whom the
system doesn't work and they're calling
out the system for its injustice for its
consumption for its exploitation for its
miss youth misuse of wealth and power
how are we doing so far so that's why
that's where the book just for those who
are like we're not going to get a vile
thing and so when you hear our Bernie
Sanders who says whether it wherever you
are politically when you hear a very
Sanders who says if you have a widening
gap between the rich and poor that's
going to be bad for everybody he is
directly channeling the Hebrew prophets
right there in the middle of the Bible
so a lot of ideas that people now think
are progressive
I'm living with intentionality and
simplicity these are central themes of
the Bible wait we didn't come up with it
well you branded it quite well
well what so then
so you had a question in there but
anyway that's I always just say that
preference for people are freaking out
so that's just very interesting to me
that thousands of years ago the things
that we are talking about people are
talking about I'm going to tell you and
Ryan can attest to this whenever we will
go out to Nevada we did an event in
Jackson Mississippi a few years ago and
this nice young couple came up to us and
they said it's great to see a couple
Christians out here spread in Jesus's
message and I just said thanks because
here's the thing if you a few weeks
later were in Seattle someone walks up
and says it's great to see a couple guys
out here spreading these Buddhist
Maxim's I said thanks and got an email
later that year and it said did you know
that Muhammad was the original
minimalist and I said thanks and what's
interesting about this and what's
interested about your work Rob is I
think in a way is like what Ryan and I
do is appealing to I mean as you can see
a broad spectrum of people and that's
because we're even Ryan and I have
radically different beliefs but we have
the same values so I give an example
Ryan and I if you look at look at us on
the myers-briggs personality says we
have exact opposite personalities we're
ying and yang
but we also have he's an extrovert I'm
an introvert one of us shows up on time
one of us doesn't
and I'm just fashionably late and here's
something for you so we both have
different religious beliefs one of the
believer one of those is it and oh we
voted for two different people in the
last election I don't know if you guys
know this or not but there's more than
there were more than just two candidates
anyway yeah we had them worried but but
what I found is that we have some some
different beliefs but we have the same
values and the beliefs tend to be a path
to get to what those what those values
are and I think I think with your work
it's really about exposing what the
values are sort of regardless of the
beliefs or even maybe even help help
people helping people question what
their beliefs are either in in with the
opportunity to change them or solidify
them and actually the one of the reasons
why I think that you all connect in such
a really visceral way is it doesn't
surprise me that people email you and
think that you're from all these
different perspectives because certain
things are true I call them true period
they've been true for thousands of years
like discipline intentionality clarity
simplicity elegance these values and
these drives have been true so it should
not surprise us that people from
different cultures religions nations
perspectives would witness to certain
things being true and I would argue that
at some level what's happening with our
culture is it's getting it's getting
more and more all treble no bass more
shrill how many YouTube videos that you
how many YouTube views did you get how
many Instagram followers hump how many
of you have had somebody mentioned
something to you and also and you feel
like I guess I'm really out of it and
then you find out that whatever it is
hit the internet an hour ago and you're
like how because the news cycle used to
be two weeks that it was like 24 hours
now it's like if you seen LeBrons new
haircut I mean he posted 17 minutes ago
three sports fans got that but you know
exactly what I'm talking about
let me try again did you see what kim
wore there so it's almost like more and
more it's moving faster faster faster
faster and when you can articulate
wisdom that is literally thousands of
years old it's like it hits a bass note
something within us goes ah thank you
that like grounds me at centers you know
talking about correct like it something
goes yeah because otherwise all it does
is just blow you back and forth all over
the place and that's I that doesn't
surprise me that you get all this plus
the way he looks you're gonna get Jesus
email I guess you can see the summer
with the sandals all right
Oh keep going you going you should it's
on the city have him come out carrying a
live lamb haha
but that'd be awesome that's genius and
then just stand here and then just walk
off yes
don't it don't do anything else just
believe it on the stage you know I'm I'm
sure the so I was of the phrase that
like you know the the idea of like what
is the Bible freaked out half the crowd
for sure and this is Rob said this is
Annabelle like religion or getting into
any of that but I think sometimes our
our interests to get piqued about
something or when I when I cringe is
something I know that maybe that I
should lean into it a little bit more
right and and so I think your work does
that in an approachable way and whether
it's a book you write or rob has a great
podcast which called the rob cast for
those of you who haven't heard it and
yeah I'm sure watch it already
it's get five on that one you know it's
what they really love it it's one of the
few podcasts I listen to regularly and
so thank you for that but yeah what
after after all of these years because
for those of you who don't know Rob Rob
used to be a pastor back in the days
back in back in Michigan Grand Rapids
and and you decided to you wrote a
groundbreaking book called Love Wins and
decided to sort of well as you put it
graduate from from that life and before
you had to divorce it in a way and so so
you came out to Los Angeles what brought
you out here because I realized in my
work when I was talking about what it
means to be human what it means to be
alive what it means to live with passion
and clarity that at some level I was
telling a story and where to where to
people tell stories and Krista and I
when we were first married lived out
here this has always felt like home so
in some ways it was like coming home yes
I love Los Angeles not like I mean like
loved it it's the prettiest like really
love I think I'll be stuck on the 405 in
traffic I'm that guy with the windows
down with smiling like you know because
I'm stuck in traffic in Los Angeles yeah
I love it here what made you at this
point want to to write a book called
what is the Bible because I noticed
especially in the past year and
especially politically how many of the
things people were talking about like oh
wait human beings have been talking
about these things for thousands of
years and sometimes what you're not
actually looking for is a solution
you're looking for solidarity like you
go through something difficult and
you're like calling your different
friends and the one friend is like well
here's what you need to do you're like
at because you don't you don't need a
lecture at that point
and finally you call a certain friend
who says yeah I know how that feels
and you were like oh that's that's why
I've been calling around to different
friends I just needed somebody to stand
with me in it
I'll fix it later that solidarity is
actually what often drives what we're
doing is we just want to know we're not
alone
and I noticed how many issues that
people were talking about for example
from the opening pages of the Bible it's
assumed that human beings have a proper
relationship with the soil that's just
an assumption and it's assumed that if
you don't treat the earth well that your
culture your politics your governance
your finances your economics would all
crumble imagine that and so a lot of
that is like a central thread of the
Bible so when people talk about our need
to care for the earth and the
extraordinary exploitation and abuse
that have gone on with the soil and that
scene is sometimes like a progressive or
a new idea it's new if you think like
about like 11,000 years old is a new
idea and I think it's really important
for people to know this that when you
stand up for injustice when you stand up
for caring for the earth when you stand
up for somebody whose rights are being
violated you are in that moment
joining a really really long human
tradition and that can invigorate you
with a certain like spinal fortitude and
strength like I'm not alone here people
have been standing up for these sorts of
things
for a really long time that's one of the
many reasons yeah what one last thing
maybe two before we dive into a question
but you're brushing up against politics
and it's always interesting when you
hear someone say but I'm not a political
person what do you say that's here okay
how many of you have running water in
your house yeah six of you more people
than have read my book excellent now
what's interesting is where was that
water source who regulated it was there
a water board Water Commission a County
Clerk who decided how much water if
there's a drought who decides how the
conservation how many households get how
many portions who appointed that person
who elected that person who brought that
person in who hired that person was that
person serving a five-year term two
ten-year term who decided somebody made
decisions and there is a long process
that is
then in play so that when you turn your
cap water comes out the ancient word
politics comes from the Greek word
Politico and it means citizens so the
politicos or politics is how the
citizens arrange our common life
together so when we all got together and
decided who's going to make sure that we
have water when we turn the tap that is
political so when someone says they're
not political I would just say do you
shower now what happened is this site
and so our shared common life together
as a member as a citizen of a county a
state a nation the world is a sacred
holy thing how many of you when you were
voting in November because obviously you
voted how many of you and you're
standing in line had like were moved
emotionally by the experience like how
many of you the next day were moved
emotionally in other ways but how many
of you when you do participate in things
like voting oh this is this matters our
shared life together matters now what
happens to this idea of politics is it
got hijacked by something called
partisanship which means for many people
they have never been in a setting where
we were overtly talking about how we
organize our common life together
where it wasn't instantly run into two
political parties and became divisive so
I would argue that the great next leap
for all of us is to returning to talk
about politics without this electric
divisive partisanship but just talk
about what is by the way if you want to
kill the tension at Thanksgiving when
your Uncle Phil wants to go all Fox News
on you I mean no one's talking about
anytime you feel like things are getting
dodgy and getting political just ask
yourself what is the policy that is in
play here because first off Sunnis are
talking about policy it's the least sexy
word in the world
it also will demonstrate quite quickly
who knows anything about what we're
talking about and that actually I think
what you're going to see is a whole new
because of what's been going on the past
year so I think you can see a whole new
generation of people go oh wait our
water our military our schools this
matters and I ought to probably know
more about this than I do because right
now I'm stuck on season five of Game of
Thrones so I clearly have the RAM space
are you with me on this I have the
storage space I'm just so excited about
Episode seven of house of cards that
drop two Fridays ago but if I knew like
2% more about my how my actual town
works
I would probably if we all did things
would be away better so that's what I
would say about
[Applause]
I think it's perfect time to answer some
questions you answer some questions with
Rob absolutely let's do it we'll start
with a couple long-winded answers and
then we'll we'll narrow it down to
something pithy er man look at that line
Josh minimal it looks like we answered
every single question here's what
happens you have to break the seal
someone has to break the ice and then
what will happen you how many people
line up because here's the thing
we hang out afterward we did shall hugs
sign books and take photos and all that
fun stuff and sadly we don't have a
chance to answer 600 questions when
we're in line so now is the time that's
the question howdy what's your name hi
I'm Claire Clara where you from yeah
awesome here at the Belasco
that's a Glasgow yes born and bred Los
Angeles would you believe I was a shyest
kid in my class you're up here bird I'm
up here first why not
so my question I've been thinking about
this for a while as I listen to your
podcast from other areas is when I was a
kid growing up in the 80s it was easy to
say oh I can't eat that this before
hydrogenated fats were introduced to say
no I can t said I'm my family Jewish I
keep kosher and it was easy you know
people are like oh no problem but now as
an adult as a parent as a wife when
people are in my presence or place in my
home that and I feel like I can't say
minimalism without them feeling shamed
and so I mean I remember going to a
friend's house recently for brunch and
she said don't don't look at my closets
don't judge me and I don't feel like I
say anything but I feel like people
being in my presence sometimes you know
why don't you learn you car or why don't
you want a bigger house and like I'm
good and I feel like I'm good or my
daughter's good isn't working so I'm
here asking what what's a good
catchphrase like I'm kosher which was it
whoa oh go ahead over yeah so I don't
usually say minimalism
but just saying I'm good doesn't seem to
work yeah I was going to say we'll stop
shaming your family with the word
minimalism I don't know they just see me
yes
being kind of contented with like
everyone my family leases cars everyone
is looking for the bigger house and they
look at me and I like so when you're
going to move and I say I'm good yeah
and when are you going to get a new card
I'm good yeah don't say minimal I think
if I was in your shoes well first off I
just want to be very clear like we are
the minimalist because the domain was
available for like eight bucks so you
know minimalism when I heard the term
minimalism right away I was like what is
minam like I pictured art I pictured you
know stark white walls maybe like a monk
and then Josh sends me this video of
Colin right and who owned like 52 things
and carried everything he owned in his
backpack being this like peripatetic
writer and i'm like josh has lost his
mind
and then he sent me the other the other
folks and what I realized is that
yeah minimalism can be subversive
absolutely it was to me at first and I
think that minimalism is kind of like
the the best word and probably like the
most imperfect word if that makes sense
like it's yeah it's imperfect because
you get all those thoughts of stark
white walls and monks and like I don't
want to look like a monk I didn't want
to like give up my kitchen table I like
having a kitchen table I don't want to
give up my couch I have game night so if
I didn't have a couch like that we'd all
sit on the floor to be uncomfortable
when I'd be you know kicking cranium
pieces all over the living room floor so
you know I guess it is it is also the
best for though because it does make
people you know kind of stop and think
but in your situation you know instead
of maybe saying I'm good I mean look at
it as
you can call it whatever you want you
can call it simplicity you can call it
intentional ISM you can call it whatever
you want it doesn't have to be
minimalism I mean when people when
people you know meet me for the first
time I don't say hi my name is Ryan
Nicodemus I'm a minimalist you know it
that would be a really weird
introduction and have you seen my
documentary um no I I usually just you
know my name is Randy Niemann and then
of course they asked that question what
do you do and I'll tell my snowboard and
it'll he make money off of snowboarding
I'm like no I live in Montana I just
love to snowboard what do you love to do
and you know I'll kind of create the or
you know take the conversation a little
bit in a different direction but you
know when someone asks you like why
aren't you why aren't you getting into
more debt what is wrong with you you
might just you can just answer it with
that I'm trying to stay out of debt I'm
trying to live a more simple life and
people will feel judged but I'll tell
you the best way I feel is to help
people not feel judged is to support
them regardless of where you're at in
your life like my mom who you know she
called me up like a month after Josh and
I launched the website and she's like
hey son how you doing I'm like I'm great
how are you she's like I'm great
what is this minimalist crap and I'm
like oh you found the website like she
must have been googling my name or
something and had to come across it and
our friend told her yeah oh yeah or
maybe a friend told her and actually I
think she was probably like we got those
52 visitors that first month I think it
was heard it's like going back to the
website fifty-two times but I'm like
what do you think about it she's like I
don't know what to think like are you
are you depressed like can I Manaka am I
not going to see you for holidays
anymore can I still buy you gifts and
I'm like yes mom I am depressed actually
and I'm trying to change that and I'm
trying to just do something different
with my life and yeah of course I'm
going to be around for the holidays like
I don't want to not see you during the
holiday
in fact I hope to see you more that was
probably the only time I ever saw her
actually she looked a half-hour away
from me I saw her maybe six or seven
times a year and you know when it came
to the gift thing I was like yeah like
please don't buy me anything
I have a lot of stuff in fact too much
stuff and I would appreciate it if you
would just hold back on any gifts please
save your 15 bucks on the tie clip that
I'll never wear and just you know you
just don't get me anything
she's like well you know I'm your mom
and I'm still gonna buy his stuff and I
suppose like she has that right as my
mother to say that and I was like I was
like well mom um if you get me something
I can't use I'm gonna get rid of it I'm
gonna have to donate it I'm going to
give it to someone finally to get home
this is not the thing to say to your
mother by the way I know yeah so if she
got it she got a little upset and we
were kind of going back and forth a
little bit and it just got to a point
where I was like mom you know I love you
and I know that you love me
she's like of course I love you I'm like
I want you to be happy I know you want
me to be happy too right so like yeah of
course I'm like well if that's the case
I don't need you to have a packing party
I don't come to your home and judge your
stuff I just need your support and I
want to support you and that that really
is what kind of is what got through to
her and that's what I've done you know
from the very beginning I don't ever go
to my mom's house and ask her like you
know you know why do you have all this
stuff or she asks me you know why do you
still have that 2004 Toyota Corolla like
you're making some money now right like
you can get you can afford a new car and
I'm like uh I still have to get it like
a payment and I don't want to get that
debt payment I'm trying to stay
debt-free I'm trying to maintain this
this simple life and I'll tell you it
took about gotta talk about three years
two years um she came to Montana to
visit me and my partner Mariah and I
picked her up at the airport brought her
bags into the apartment we had just
moved into the place like a month prior
to that and as soon as she open opens up
her bags like she pulls out this vase
and like a couple
candlestick holders and right away I'm
like she's like like what am I going to
do with this stuff and I'm just like
smiling and I'm not going to start it
again not going to judge her I'm not
going to look at her and say I can't use
this I'm gonna go I'm gonna get you know
I'm gonna get rid of this but before I
could even like really react or say
anything to it she said you know son
like you have come so far and I'm so
proud of you and I know that this is
your new home and I just wanted to like
give you a housewarming gift and show
you how much I appreciate you and then
she said it doesn't fit with your life
feel free to find it a new home I
totally understand but I just wanted to
give this to you to let you know that I
love you and then I'm proud of you took
her two years to get to that point and
now you know what her plan is I love
this I love my mother man she is going
to her plan right now she's saving up to
buy an RV yeah so she can drive around
the country and do open mic nights I
swear to God I swear to God is my mom's
claims and I support her 100%
like I want to be like okay mom like I
will help you write your jokes like all
right like if you want to make fun of
minimalism on your tour great like I've
got a lot of you know a lot of irony
that was that we can we can pick on but
but but the whole point is is that when
it comes to your friends when it comes
to your family if they love you if they
want you to be happy they're gonna
support you you might have to ask for it
but they will absolutely do that
and if you support them they have no
reason to not support you've got friends
in your life who are judging you for not
getting into more debt are they really
your friends notice me usually more with
my daughter's peers and they'll come to
our house and they're like this is so
cute mm-hmm and tidy so your front your
daughter's friends the classmates are
there judging your daughter
are they really her friends now there's
4 years old yeah okay well
sir-sir you know and what's nice is
eternal space yeah what to be cordial
and polite and you know and so it's just
it's funny because the place that it's
most embraced for me is at work because
it's like a battle to always kind of
pack last spring less but yeah it just I
find like I just I'm missing that phrase
to say to people to just kind of give
them the passage no no it's okay it's
okay
because of saying like it's good or I'm
okay just I don't know I feel like if
you're looking for a phrase here's the
phrase for you I would just say long
story short I would not care what where
you will four-year-old spot about me
that's just me personally so I know
that's their parents if you're looking
for something to say other than I'm good
you know the thing that I that I tend to
say and I say it so much don't quite a
bit as I have enough whenever I'm
wanting to make a decision and thinking
about wiring something new feeling
judged in any way I have enough because
I am enough right in an empty room I'm
enough and everything else that I put in
my life has to augment that experience
of life not get in the way of it thanks
to something yeah I love hearing about
the journey you're on your family may
never understand uh they won't I've
accepted yeah and I think sometimes the
danger is well I know like with you I'd
be like I hear what's the thing I can
say but it's almost like this culture is
like swimming in water and unless you
drag a fish up on beat on the beach and
like point back to the water
this system of however many thousand of
advertisements a day bigger faster
stronger more Amazon just bought Whole
Foods near 13 billion this addiction to
scale up and to the right more features
better look at it stores more things why
is that good because it stores more
things it helps me to think about it
systemically that until and
consciousness of the great mystery
until you have seen you don't know what
somebody's talking about who has seen
and once you've seen you can't unsee and
once you taste you can't untaped you you
have seen and tasted a better way of
living and I feel that the great mystery
is until a person has seen or tasted
that no matter we can bend over
backwards explaining but sometimes
people have no idea what we're talking
about and you're I'm so glad here
sometimes you have to make peace with
that on the front end otherwise we're
like trying to convince people of things
or even just come up with language that
isn't ever going to work which is the
opposite of his answer thank you thank
you thank you
hey what's up brother what's up man how
are you good yeah man oh yeah
you know I had this like really deep
serious question and then Ryan said
about you know his mom doing open mic
night and I first thing come to mind is
how many minimalist does it take to
screw in a light bulb that's a joke
real clean notes you know the answer to
that I'm guessing a lot well you have to
first find it so how many minimalist
does it take to screw in a light bulb
well it's 0 because minimalists don't
have light bulbs real question though is
that I love how you guys use instead of
pitching people on minimalism kind of
you know using the question now how
might your life be better with less
instead of you know the pitch of a you
know listicles of here's the 10 features
in bottle blah blah blah and I think
that's great also too for many things
other than just minimalism and I've used
that in many times in my life you know
how might like me better if the bling
and I love mineral ISM as I'm sure most
people here do but like when you get
into something you know you're searching
for it you're researching it you get
into this kind of echo chamber or bubble
of just a reaffirming you know there's
algorithms now social media that does
that where like you find all this
information to reaffirm and so I thought
have you ever asked yourself like the
inverse of that quiet
how might my life be better with more
and I guess in parentheses what would
that more can you know be made up out of
yeah yeah so we live my life now it's in
a way that I have fewer things with
better things right and so more can be
more quality more really has to do I
mean when Ryan was talking earlier more
has to do with the other areas of life I
was so bogged down with stuff whether it
was you know the 300 thousand items I
had but it was in the way and I forced
took the people closest to me my health
was out of control and I weighed 80
pounds more than I weigh now and my
relationships were in shambles was the
reason my marriage ended and I felt like
I didn't have control of my creativity
or my time and I was constantly pursuing
something I didn't want to pursue I was
working really hard to spend money I
didn't have on things I didn't want to
impress people I didn't know and and
once I figured out that I didn't have to
go do that then what is the more and I
made room for that more and some of it
is stuff I mean I'm not against I'm not
an ascetic right I don't want to steep
myself and perpetual suffering so that I
can learn to deal with pain that you
have you have light bulbs in your house
yes yes if I do they're smart light
bulbs too but the truth is that the
things that I bring into my life now I
am questioning that those are that value
to my life but also the things that add
value today at age 35 may not add value
at age 45 or 55 or whatever and so I
have to keep asking that question it's
not a static sort of thing I wish there
was a list I could hand to you and say
here are the 100 items you should own
and now you'll be happy because then it
would be so much easier to be a one page
book and all of you go home happy but
the truth is we have to keep asking what
is that more well what am i what am I
going to bring into my life and why and
more important why is it important
yeah I totally agree with him I mean
even in the beginning of the talk I'm
like imagine your life with more time
that was the first reason why I even got
into this whole thing I was what my Josh
is tell me about minimalism and then I
started to see like oh this is some very
very common-sense stuff in fact like
people they will will be on the radio
and like they'll call in and they'll say
this is a really really old idea this is
just really common sense and I'm like
yeah the common sense a to common these
days unfortunately and it took someone
like you know seeing how Josh was living
his life and for him to kind of share
those grounded principles that I
automatically felt connected to and I
was like oh yeah if I don't have this
huge mortgage hanging over my head if
I'm not going out and buying a brand new
car every couple years maybe I won't
have to work this 6070 sometimes 80
hours a week job I mean the whole thing
for me man I just I wanted to pay off my
debt I wanted to save up enough money to
where I felt like it was about six
months worth of bills and I felt like I
could finally transition away from my
job and become a barista like that was
my dream and then you know this this
beautiful accident happened with the
website and you know maybe one day I'll
be able to like go and be a barista
because you know I'm debt free and right
now let's say the internet blew up and
all of our books spontaneously combusted
and you know all of a sudden like no one
no one shows up you know the rug is
sweet swept out from underneath of us
dude I'll go be a barista like I have no
problem doing I might have to move
apartments because I don't think I could
you know live in my Missoula apartment
living off of twenty three thousand
bucks a year but I have no lease I have
no debt like I could very easily just
just walk away
and go and be a barista and for me like
that that was the more was more time to
actually focus on what my priorities
were so going from that eighty hours a
week to you know thirty
40 hours a week would have been great if
I could have just got back down to that
honestly thanks a lot thank good howdy
hello what's going on Ryan Ryan actually
hey Ryan a cool name in going on so I
have a statement followed by question I
I didn't actually read your guys's book
but I get out of here man still still in
a huge job security I still am a huge
I'm totally kidding man and I may be
watched part of the death on one of them
uh but but point being is that I do love
you guys
but you're here thank you so much yeah
my mom actually my mom actually bought
me a ticket to the front row and I was
like yeah why not Friday but so uh point
being in this Rob I didn't know you were
going to be here and I'm so grateful man
I mean you said just probably less than
like 2,000 words
and Marty in love with you yeah maybe
that much but you and me both Ryan you
and me both
so point being is that I actually when I
was younger growing up my mom had a lot
of problems with the way that I would
structure my life just because you know
clean your room all this kind of stuff
but at about 16 17 years old right
around then I actually found minimalism
on my own I wasn't religious I was sort
of a reader but I didn't find it in
books so much I just kind of cleaned my
room one day and I was like damn oh my
god this was amazing and I just it never
stopped being that way and I moved out
of the house now
and as you guys can tell I can't really
be much older than seventeen at this
point and I already have my own place
and I'm still kind of you know steeped
in minimalism I don't have many things
it's always been that way
but when finally after you know neatly
removing things from my mom's apartment
and trying to get her onto this boat and
her fighting every step of the way
finally I'm I'm you know sitting on that
beach enjoying you know the palm trees
around me and I finally hear her
flopping out of the water and now I can
point back and we're like she
understands it now she kind of gets it
now she's inviting me to be the
minimalist thing
but my question being I've kind of found
the deeper rooted sense of happiness in
this but how do i how do I bring her
further or how do people bring
themselves further afterwards this is
kind of building off of what the two
people before me asked but where do you
find that really rooted sense of
happiness I mean you go snowboarding I
do I got I love skiing and all these
other small little knickknacks mcnac
sports and things like that but where's
that rooted sense of happiness how can
you find happiness at like a 10-day
meditation retreat so I would start with
buying our three books Ryan I totally
gave just could you around here can I
can I can I give Ryan all three of our
books so I don't feel like I'm selling
him something I'm totally Dugan which by
the way they're available in the lobby
afterwards but 100 percent of the
profits go to our favorite charity the
Josh and Ryan gas fun to get to San
Francisco no Ryan I think that I think
chasing happiness is actually the
problem thank you guys oh thank you guys
a lot thank you I I think that the
chasing happiness is is really the
problem and it's what I did for a really
long time and I think yet to be really
careful with that because it's sort of
like if you boil up a balloon and just
let it go
that's sort of what I was doing just
going every direction looking for
happiness right and so I I started
searching for what a more meaningful
life looked like for me and really for
me then aligning my short-term actions
with my long-term values in order to do
that you have to figure out what are
your values whose be a person that you
aspire to be like you know what's your
twenty eight-year-old self now here's
the thing I'm not saying you know write
down your ten goal wasn't that's what
you want what kind of person do you want
to be what are your values and once you
identify what your values are you can
start to align your daily actions with
that for the longest time I said my
priorities or one thing I said my health
or my relationships or whatever but our
real priorities are how we spend our
day and so I was incessantly checking
email or Facebook and going from meeting
to meeting to meeting
he showed me your calendar I'll show you
your priorities and and what I realized
is that if I want to be the person that
I actually wanted to be that I because I
identified that as a meaningful life I'd
have to change what I do every day and
here's here's the good news
happiness is a really beautiful
byproduct of that that's good
the Japanese there's a Japanese word a
key guy and it means key guy means that
which gets you up in the morning by the
way I was doing this one time with a
group and a guy came up afterwards he's
like I speak Japanese it's a key guy and
I was like and I don't and if the key
guy because I'm not going to say a key
guy but uh a key guy is that which gets
you up in the morning and there's this
very well developed philosophy of what
is it that gets you up and when you no
longer have an icky guy then you're
you're dead even if you aren't dead and
it's understood that you're a key guy is
something you're endlessly working out
over the course of your life and it may
be different things at different times
and the reason why I tell you that is
because right before this event started
Ryan was said to me I can't believe I
get to do this what gets you up in the
morning is that which fills you with a
sense of wonder and awe that you even
get to do this some days the the Wonder
and awe meter might be a little low but
your ki guy is this sense of your sense
of wonder and awe about your own
existence that you actually get to do
this the great Abraham Joshua Heschel
said I didn't ask for success I asked
for wonder and so what happened did you
live in a culture that boughs down at
the altar of success but you can be very
successful and have no wonder in aw no
look at this look what we're doing look
what we get to do and if you can can
keep trying things and keep giving
yourself to things until you find
something where you think I could do
that this would get me out of bed the
morning now you're on to something and
it will always involve two things it
will always involve a deep sense of
significance and meaning on your own on
your interiors and I would argue that it
will always involve blessing serving and
giving to someone else this will be good
not just for you this will be good for
the world
and those two things and if you don't
have those two polarities they're not
opposites they're polarities if you only
have the one this is good for me I love
this I love this but it does no good to
the greater world that's an inward focus
life it'll never work if it's just
serving them because I'm supposed to you
end up with this weird martyr complex
and it sucks all the joy out of life and
you end up bitter resenting the very
people you're trying to help but if
these two are dancing together your own
sense of joy and your sense that you
might even be contributing to the
greater good and those two are moving
together now you have something yeah
personal question for you how do you how
do you personally find that sense of
flow where you're really not trying to
do
you're really not trying you know I
because I see I can see that coming off
of you you really just don't because
everything that could go wrong did
beautiful I've been booed and had
hecklers and had protesters everything
that could go wrong did
and at some point life beat you down and
you either become bitter and cynical and
jaded and one more person staying at a
distance going that only got 27 on
Rotten Tomatoes they're like one more
person who's just throwing stones
cynicism is easy so for some people the
bruises and the beatdowns of life you
just end up one more person who's just
withdrawn from the game and now you're
just playing out why all this stuff
sucks or it beats you down and you
realize that we're here and it may
completely fail but
but we might as well give it a shot and
we do have today and no one may like
this and I may have people throw rotten
vegetables at me but man that would get
me out of bed in the morning that's how
it works in a nutshell the motivation
it's awesome
hey Ryan I just want to say dude when
you're done reading those minimize them
afterwards like do it into a library or
you know give them to a friend or give
it but what's that I shall read gift
them yeah or we gift them if they're
sitting on your bookshelf in a year and
you have and you hadn't read them yet
six months even just get rid of a man
probably the best advice I got that I
made take care bro Oh Ryan you know what
I you you Ryan you know top it is oh
yeah you know what time it is it is time
for our hashtag ask the minimalist
lightning round live from LA so this is
where we usually answer questions with a
140 character tweet a full response that
you can share on social media by the way
to take any photos or whatever the night
you can share that there's a hashtag
lessons now which is the name of the
tour as well but you can ask a normal
question we will try to give you a short
answer it doesn't always work out that
way I wanted to give you something with
a nice little flow on it to take home
and all of you could take it home as
well and it's hopefully a maximum that's
worth sharing what's your name
hi I'm Anna and actually this is more of
a statement than a question so I'm
really really quick I'm actually the
community leader for the LA area and
meet you thank you first of all thank
you thank you for validating how I have
felt all of my life and I thought I was
a little odd when I didn't want things
and I was happy with really simple
things
so this journeys been really really
great for me just so that everyone knows
we do have monthly meetings here in LA
they they do move around a little bit it
is a Facebook based group so if you
follow the minimalist look for the
minimalist the LA group and the
events will show up there sure yeah you
just go to minimalist org few years ago
Ryan and I went on a hundred city tour
and each city people come up to us and
say hey how do I connect with
open-minded people locally and I would
just sort of give them the the blank
stare and blank a few times and then say
I don't know OkCupid
but no we decided to leave behind these
these free local meetup groups in
hundreds of different cities and some of
them are really thriving and meet at
least once a month so thank you for
running that I really appreciate it
thank you thank you it's great it's been
great for me a really real pleasure so
my simple question is and that has come
up almost in every meeting 90% of the
people who show are women uh-huh is that
common because it comes up almost
everything like we have like the token
man one was 15 you know 14 women one guy
I mean you look at the room here there's
plenty of men here but come into the hub
speaking of OkCupid right any single men
out there I want to go through the up
I'm kidding don't use it as a dating
group that's not crazy
um yeah you know I don't know why in
terms of our message what I've found is
our message is broadly appealing
especially since the documentary came
out you'll see people at our events
tonight I'm willing to bet you there's a
factory worker and an executive in the
crowd there is a college or a high
school dropout and a college professor
in the crowd that there's going to be
young old rich poor young wait I said
that young again but if you have more
young people showing up because the
documentary now but people from
everywhere on the socio-economic
spectrum and I think we're all asking
the same questions how do I get back a
little bit of control I feel like I've
lost control at some point whether I'm a
CEO or I'm struggling to pay the bills
how do I get back control of the lights
I'm leaving because I'm leading because
I want to live a more meaningful life
and so I can't answer you why
specifically why is that this particular
group because in other cities it is
either the opposite or it's 50/50 it
kind of depends on on on
individual group and so what I'll say to
you is you all here Los Angeles's you
have opportunity here to meet with with
a group of open-minded people I say
open-minded I don't say like-minded I
think it's important to realize like I
said even Ryan and I are like-minded but
people were willing to listen
willing to be supportive and you can
talk but it's not a decluttering group
you can talk about whatever you want
careers health you talk about your stuff
too but really want to leave that behind
for you so you can connect with people
locally great and it's a great group I
have to tell you it's really it's been a
positive experience every weekend we get
together and we don't want to leave like
people need to go over like okay yeah
you go we're just going to stand here
and keep you know keep talking so it's
awesome thank you very cool thank you
thank you all right so now we're
starting to lining around yeah okay look
out it I was going Josh Ryan
awesome thanks for coming out what's
your name a brother names James has
opportunity walked you guys
documentaries recently and fizzled point
when Joshua and salt buds and you're
talking about
even when Rome is burning there's still
time to shop at IKEA and that you had
the chance like your mom passed away
your marriage is ending but yet I can
still had this desire to shop like a
really struck a chord with me because
seeing like this culture where everyone
is consuming it's like know like why do
we have to you this we should just let
it go and coming across you guys's blog
what listening to Justin bollock the guy
who narrated your audio book came across
optimal finance daily and then optimal
living daily and then kind of marries
the two between financial independence
be like early retirement and then
minimalism because it kind of goes hand
in hand
your loss amount of stuff you bought
more money you can take home you can
take home to earth or you can retire and
happier you can be have you seen that
kind of as a whole with people that come
to see you like they kind of want that
yeah so the question has a lot to do
with the the finance is tie into the
minimalism thing and for me that they
did so it's your question spawned with
CNN documentary when I was talking about
I was reading out in the Salt Flats in
Utah there was no one in the first
reading I've ever done that no one
attended just out there the middle of
nowhere I'm reading from everything that
remains and the line is but even while
Rome is burning there's somehow time for
shopping at IKEA and it's because my mom
died my marriage ended I'm like moving
into a new apartment I'm out shopping so
I know I was in Ikea a few months ago
and someone recognized me awkward this
that wasn't a commentary on IKEA was a
comment commentary on my own priorities
but speaking of priorities my finances I
made really good money in the corporate
world but I spent even better money and
that equation never works that's my pity
answer that's a good one you have
anything piss me Ryan I'm going to
ramble a little bit until maybe I get to
something but the UH the short answer is
yes like I had I was walking in earlier
to do the sound check and there's a
gentleman gentleman out there I think
his name was Nick if it's not Nick I
know you're a sir I'm so sorry if I
remembered your name wrong but he came
up to me he was like man you know you
guys always talk about finances you
always talk about you know living a debt
free life and not accumulating more debt
and he was like you know I just took on
a job that I am going to make more money
I am going to have to work a little bit
more he's like but I really want to get
to that point and I really respected
that because in the beginning of the
talk when I'm like you know talking
about imaginary life with less and all
that I say you know I'm not talking
about a perfect life or even an easy
life but a simple one because we often
confuse simple with easy and simple is
actually very very difficult in a lot of
cases and in this gentleman's case like
it is difficult I mean to live the
simple life he wants to live he is going
to have to he got himself into a hole
and he's going to have to get himself
out of it and it is going to take a lot
of work
maybe that's my tweetable answer what to
pay yourself out of a hole nobody shot
there's open oh okay all right let me
rephrase it thank you josh is my
wordsmith so I guess that would be my
answer is if you dig in yourself into a
hole there isn't an easy way to get out
of it it's going to take a lot of work
thank you for your time
hold on oppas gonna have to have
something to do with the finances
everything is spiritual most
specifically your finances and your
savings and your soul are deeply
interconnected and the more debt you
have the less oxygen your soul has so
every move you make towards financial
freedom is like taking another layer off
of your heart and your spirit so you can
actually soar 140 yes no man yeah when
that would take gentlemen I thought I
told you we tie it up with a pretty
little bow right no the tweetable quote
man was the more debt you have the less
oxygen your soul has like that is that's
beautiful ma'am
yeah yeah what's up brother what's your
name Michael hello gentlemen howdy honey
you guys ever secretly buy [ __ ] and hide
it from each other
oh man that we honest I'm gonna give my
I have so much material for my mother to
go on the roadway yeah I mean honestly
Ryan is the most honest person that I've
ever met and so I mean I don't think he
would ever hide anything from me
but um yeah I doubt there's some like
jet ski and his and his garage or
something I'm a thinker matte mansion in
Malibu you don't even know about no man
I wish I had a sexy answer for you like
yeah I really love beanie babies when I
got my check out my fabric J egg
collection beanie babies like 1995
called man they want their collection
bag no now I'm sorry I wish shot a
better answer for you you know real
pleasure to see you guys thank you
brother oh my god
we got time for one more question before
we move on to her added-value segment so
I apologize other people in line I
promise you'll get a hug afterward if
you if you stick around
howdy what's your name hi my name is Sam
okay from Ventura California welcome I'm
super nervous so thank you but I just
wanted to start off by you guys have
helped shape my life and like the past
year dramatically and the biggest thing
that I've taken away is letting go of
toxic people and I think I've done an
incredible job I'm down to like three
friends and I'm so happy about
I've never been happier with genuine
people in my life so my question is I
have a very toxic person in my life and
they have an addiction and my question
is is how do you divorce somebody when
they're your parents and they're
bringing a toxic environment not only to
your life but to it's causing me to have
a toxic relationship slightly with my
husband or you know it brings up some
commotion or it's holding me back from
being a better sister or even being a
best daughter that I can be to them and
I'm having a really really hard time
with pulling myself away from somebody
who's so toxic so how do you walk away
from somebody who will always love but
you don't want to be a part of that kind
of environment I will start with a pithy
answers and I'll try to unpack it a
little bit the thing that I've learned
over the years is that victims become
victimizers and and so I had people in
my life for sure that played the victim
role repeatedly and and dragged me down
with them and so we all hear the sort of
platitudes of you are the five people
you surround yourself with your five
closest friends and and that ends up
being true and so I think one way for
you to to remove yourself from that it's
that not run away from that but to run
towards something else and find
relationships and people who are going
to be supportive people with similar
values and and I think that ultimately
when you're when you're dealing with
someone who you've been so close to for
a really long time you can't help
someone that doesn't want help I guess
my biggest fear is walking away and then
losing them and not having that I guess
it's like how much do I give of myself
to try and help them when I get in back
of my mind I also know too
that they can only help themselves yes
are you do you think this person will
change on their own I want to believe
that they sure but I can't answer that
only they can well then I'll give you my
short answer it's one that you've heard
before probably you can't change the
people around you but you can change the
people around you and I think you have
to surround yourself with some
supportive relationships and model you
have to model the behavior that you want
to see from from that parent and in
doing so either great hope is that they
will follow I mean the nice thing is a
lot of people in my life from from my
20s they thought I was crazy and I had
to walk away from that but eventually
when I modeled the behaviors that I
wanted to see and myself they ended up
following man um I'm so sorry to hear
about your situation night nobody's long
no it's not I just I've been there and
yeah it does uh man I hate to like air
out all my dirty laundry um but like I
have I have a relative I'll just say
that I have a relative in prison right
now who is because of drugs and they
were in prison they got out I was
helping them as much as I could brought
them out to my home gave them some money
to you know start a new life with and
they ended up back in prison again so
when they did they called me up and
they're like hey man can you give me
money for a lawyer and I'm like no like
I'm sorry but I can't I'm not willing to
do that like I'm willing to write you
I'm willing to talk to you I'm willing
to support you whenever you want but
supporting you with in a monetary
fashion like that's just in my opinion
enabling you and I've already done that
and it hasn't done anything
you and that's not any knock against you
I just know that until you really really
want to change no matter how much money
I give you or stuff but whatever it is
until you really want to change like
nothing is actually going to change in
your life so I guess what I'm saying is
is um even other family members like
they still they still don't get what I'm
doing they you know if I see them they
always got to make some kind of smarten
nice orange shoelaces minimalist like I
can't believe you have colored shoelaces
and you know is that shirt adding value
to your life I mean just constantly take
a drink and you know at the end of the
day like those family members I do love
them so much but I will distance myself
and some of them have to completely come
around and my relative who's in prison
right now like I we still have a good
relationship there is nothing I can do
to change to change them they're going
to have to change themselves but I will
still be there for them
I would say don't that I don't think you
have to walk them I mean maybe you do I
don't know this is just my two cents I
would say you know maybe you don't have
to walk completely away from from this
relationship as much as distance
yourself as much as possible still show
them that you care and love them and
support them in every way that you can
but don't ever support someone for the
sake or does my pit the answer I got it
don't go out of your way to support
someone and forsake your own meaningful
life from some people you have to love
from a distance and that means you're
going to have to have a funeral for the
parents and the relationship you wish
you had and that will involve grieving
because they haven't been able to come
with you so the real question to ask is
how much can you engage with somebody
without losing yourself and if you find
that two hours of engagement takes you
two weeks to flush the toxins out or you
and your husband have to do like a week
of am I crazy because they lobbed all
that stuff like a Katy Perry melody it
got stuck in the front of your head how
many of you have someone in your life
who they know how to say something that
gets looped in your frontal cortex and
it just plays on repeat so here's the
thing you don't have to be around that
and and the great heartache this
literally thousands of year olds old is
what happens when you find yourself at
odds with your own tribe maybe even the
people who brought you into the world
because your path has not continued on
alongside their path and so a second you
asked your question I was oh grieving
grieving think about it I am grieving
what I wish I had and then you have to
continue on your path and maybe it means
loving people from a distance thank you
man that's what I'm man so this will
read let's move on to what we call the
added value segment it shows where Ryan
and I you should talk about something
that's added value to our lives recently
while we're out on tour we love to do a
little bit of a local flare so Ryan what
what is the added value to your life in
Los Angeles maybe we can get Rob
involved as well so he lives there I'm
sure there's something in Los Angeles
that adds value to your like a couple
couple things maybe oh um all right so
the last time Josh and I were in LA he's
like hey man
well let me just backtrack a little bit
more so in Missoula Montana he's like
hey man do you want to come and hang out
in the sauna with me and then I take
these really cold showers and then we
get back in the sauna then we take cold
showers and I could have put like 6:00
a.m. and I do this and I'm like okay
like I'll try and I got up at 6:00 a.m.
and I did this with him and um god it
was miserable I'm not gonna lie and I
never did it again mainly because it was
you know me having to be somewhere at
6:00 a.m. but uh but the last time we
were not like he's like hey man I know
like the whole sauna and shower like
wasn't your thing he's like what you've
got to check out this this bath house
that I go to and he was like it's kind
of what we did he's like but it's a
little bit more a little bit more
tolerable and you know it's like no
offense to Missoula Montana or the wiser
but it's kind of janky there he's like
this is a really nice place like you're
gonna love it
and he took me to vote a spa and it's a
Russian bathhouse and yeah like they
have like a dry like a dry Russian sauna
they have a wet Russian sauna a Turkish
sauna and they have this cold plunge
which I don't know why that's easier for
me than like letting the cold water like
run on me because this is six o'clock in
the morning by the way in like December
and Montana and the heating element that
they had that keeps the water at a
certain temperature was broken
morning so it was just like super cold
water like showering on me
but anyway long story short we've been
here for against like a week now and
I've been there twice me and Mariah both
and it is it is so invigorating it is
like I can't even explain it what Josh
the first time he took me to this to
this spot like we were we did like these
the cycle of hanging out in the sauna
for 10 or 15 minutes and then you go
into the cold plunge like I think I
could stand it for maybe a minute and we
get out there in Lake everything is just
kind of spinning and josh is like is
this what it feels like to do shrooms
and I'm like not like if you drink like
a half a pint of whiskey or something
this is like what drunk feels I've known
Josh like like he said since we were fat
little fifth graders and he has never
touched a sip of alcohol I've never seen
him do I know I've never seen to take a
puff of a cigarette I just my mom drank
enough for the whole family so I you
know Josh goes to the spa to get his
clothes on I guess but uh but no like if
you haven't if you haven't been to vote
as well like I would totally recommend
it me and Mariah went like I said twice
we absolutely love it and actually
speaking of mariah are you up there
I just want to say thank you to my
partner I have such an awesome partner I
mean to be able to go onto the road
she's doing like a coding school right
now where she has to spend 6 to 8 hours
a day reading sometimes I look at her
computer screen it looks like she's
hacked into the matrix or something like
I have no idea what's going on and so I
was like hey you gotta come out to LA
with me on this wave and she was like I
can almost worked it I'm like you know
come on she's like okay so she's finding
time to work on that but just having a
supportive partner like there's no way
in the world not just having an awesome
best friend who is so supportive but
having a a partner who supports me
whether she's with me or not I just want
to say thank you so much Mariah for
being awesome I love
so much before I talk about what's been
adding value to my life Rob what uh what
has been adding value to your life in
Los Angeles these days
well that list is long no Russian
bathhouse ah ah there's a spot that I
serve between the Santa Monica Pier in
the Venice pier and generally there's a
spot that nobody's out so you sit out
there alone and almost every time I'm
out it gonna happen again tomorrow
morning a pod of dolphins will come
through and often they come through and
then they encircle you and you're
sitting among among them and sometimes
they jump out of the water and sometimes
there's like a baby up against a mother
and they're sort of curl your toes
instinctively like because there's just
fins and things all around that's the
first thing in a second
the second thing on a completely
different level is right around the
corner from here is a store called the
last bookstore which is like something
where junior Tolkien and JK Rowling had
a baby that built a store with Kurt it's
you all know what I'm talking about
right because you don't wait there and
then you come out and it's June or
October and you realize you've been in
there for a while it's amazing yeah it's
a great book shop but it's my favorite
you have to been like just going going
there and going to the top floor is
totally worth it and I'm not going to
say anything other than that if you
haven't been there just go over there go
to the top floor it's freaking awesome
yeah it's a good job well you know
there's an album that I listen to
it's called drinking from the Salt Pond
and every time I listen to it it makes
me think about Los Angeles like it
sounds like Los Angeles and it's by band
called run River North Judas who we were
grateful enough to open up for us
tonight I want to bring them out onto
the stage to sing one song from that
album it's called run or hide hey
everybody
[Applause]
so we're big fans of music and we've
never had a chance to see them live
until tonight and so this was just
really a ploy so that we could get to
see you live a chapter thank you so much
for being here tonight trick that thank
you for having us man yeah we're going
on tour in like three days and my wife
is like why aren't you not at home right
now so I need to have a good excuse when
I when I'm done with this song this song
is called run or hide and it's off thank
you for saying that it sounds like la we
it feels really good thanks appreciate
it we don't even really hear a lot of
the compliments we just play shows and
then we get out so feels good the song
called run or hide and yeah
[Music]
I'm in the dining with your shadow
shadow hanging over me shaking the
ground your first sports that's calling
out
[Music]
you
[Music]
after the races already faces keep
rolling by me now I don't understand I'm
in my hand all of the same I'll look the
same I think I changed my mind
about a million times run her high to
run or hide I'm gonna call this out of
coming back somehow
I won't run or hide I won't run or hide
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm steering apart
I see the brake brake but I can't let
them stop so I let them in I feel them
feel them tearing of Moscow I think I
changed my mind
about a million times Oh to run alive Oh
to run or I'm gonna call this out I'm
coming back somehow I won't run or hide
I won't run
ah round Norma
run
[Applause]
lying flat you hear you only give what
you get you're trying to keep this and
spit it out spit it out the lines that
you hear you only give what you get
trying to keep this is spit it out spit
it out think I changed my mind about a
million times
Oh to run hot or run or hide I'm gonna
call this out I'm coming back somehow I
won't run your hot
I won't run oh hi nothing to change my
mind about a million times
Oh to run aha Oh to run our hi I'm gonna
hold it down I'm coming back
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
unbelievable I'll grab now by the way I
think they got a parking ticket during
sound check so if you want to get that
album at their booth I think it'll help
pay for that after the show they also
have a new EP EP at Kolkata
superstition so you can check that out
as well let's wrap it up real quick I
want to say thanks to the Belasco
theater for having us here in Los
Angeles look at this amazing place it's
called the gaol we'll call the book she
was she'll be back there her name is
Jess we'll be hanging out in about 20
minutes so we'll come and do hugs and
photos and all that stuff but Jess
handles all of our social media we bring
her on the road so that we don't have to
stay addicted to our phones we're really
fortunate in that respect so I want to
give Jess a round of applause thanks
she also runs the minimalist org meetup
groups and does a bunch of stuff for for
the minimalists also recording this
tonight the man behind the minimalism he
really does everything he's our tour
manager or podcast producer and
all-around outstanding guy his name is
Shawn Harding we call him podcast Shawn
and of course what y'all think of Rob
Bell he's a great human being and we're
grateful you decided to spend the time
with us tonight Rob thanks for being on
the stage we really appreciate it yeah
what an honor thank you
and most important I want to thank you
I know cost some money to get in here
which enables us to rent theaters and do
some really cool stuff with this we
can't show up with 600 people to a
coffee shop anymore these days it just
wouldn't work out but really grateful
you decided to spend some money to be
here tonight but more important you gave
up your two most precious resources
tonight you gave up your time and your
attention and we're grateful for that
and if you leave here with just one
message we hope with this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for being here y'all thank you so
much LA thank you so much
hi this is Terry porta I'm an artist in
Billings Montana I just found your blog
and it's just very much a breath of
fresh air I want to thank you for that I
also want to encourage all those parents
out there my husband and I just embarked
on to the minimalist well I'd been doing
this in my life in little ways and
suddenly becoming so anxious over all
the clutter in my life and didn't know
what to name it and then suddenly
someone I don't know where I found it
but the minimalist like came up and I
found you guys just literally bumbling
around and they had the internet trying
to find anything I could about
decluttering and just you know
downsizing and we have a young son who's
seven and if he leaps back he got in
really big trouble and for for being in
trouble I actually went into his room
which he's a little inventor and he's a
boy so he collects a lot of stuff
everywhere he goes he finds a treasure
and I went into his room with trash bags
and put every single blasted thing I
could find and put my hands on in trash
bags he was there and because it was
such a big punishment for what he did he
had gotten the most severe punishment
well inadvertently we had minimalized
his entire room all he had was wood
floors in his bed and his clothes which
were all organized I mean we literally
took everything and he was going to earn
them back and and slowly over time what
he earned back he could keep or whatever
but it was just like this is that's the
end of the straw well we were so
surprised and scratching her head
because he stopped even wanting to earn
it all back
he loved his room all nice and clean and
he wanted just some real basic things
that he truly loved he wanted those back
so he worked hard and got those back but
after that he stopped even asking us
about it and even
today like his room was a little bit too
cluttered he will sit there and he this
is not his personality I mean he's not a
clean person you know by nature but it
seemed like to us that he didn't even
like living in that just constant
clutter all the time and just being
seven years old and he doesn't even know
his the full scope of what he did for us
but going into his room made us sigh
with relief
my name is Carly I'm calling from Salma
California I also had a terrible
childhood that I'm just now starting to
heal from and I am remembering that
early on I began to collect sentimental
things letters friends clothes letters
from friends excuse me clothes etc early
on things that made me feel good because
I didn't a lot of the time my dad also
collects many things pictures videos
albums guitars Asian decor Native
American decor cetera and I always
really didn't like that about our house
in my adult life I also discovered that
I'll keep the last cookie or the last
bit of popcorn just in case and then I
have to throw it out and that's a
problem so anyways I explained my
situation a little bit on the 26 year
old single mom of two girls ages two and
five I'm a full-time student have been
since my youngest was six weeks old I
have no income and going to be filing
for bankruptcy and I just wanted a
journey of finding a finding figuring
out how to be happy just being in the
present and enjoying life alone by
myself
and to show my girls love and how to
enjoy life and love themselves
intrinsically not because of what they
have or what they look like as I began
this emotional journey of letting go a
dear friend contacted me out of nowhere
after years of not speaking and saying
Carly I need to come see you I know
something's telling me I need to come
see you so she came and she saw my house
and she was just started helping me box
things up and teach me how to arrange
things in a way that's a positive for
song shui etc not let me do your podcast
you two are on my mind daily Josh and
Ryan I love your pithy answers because I
can remember them and they helped me not
buy something or they helped me go ahead
and toss something the 20/20 rule etc hi
Josh and Ryan this is Ashley from San
Francisco California I'm a huge fan of
you
website and podcast I have an essay
topic for you
write a letter to your 25 year old self
and a letter to your 45 year old self it
doesn't have to be those exact ages I'm
going to try to try the same exercise
with myself when I'm curious to see is
the wisdom that I've hopefully gained in
the past decade and more importantly the
hopes that I have for my future self so
I can start living up to that version of
myself now I just thought I'd share this
idea with you both in case you found
value in it thank you for all you do and
keep up the great work
everybody's Joshua Fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist we're going home to the
Midwest smooth we are indeed we're
bringing the left is now tour back to
Indianapolis Cincinnati Columbus and
Cleveland it's our old stomping ground
we're looking forward to seeing you
we're going to give an in-depth talk
about minimalism we're going to record a
live version of the minimalist podcast
we're going to answer a bunch of folks
questions along the way and of course
free totally optional hugs out yes now
whenever we visit a city we're not just
on the lessons now tour we're on a
different kind of tour
yeah we're also on the museum tour the
Thai food tour the best coffee tour so
if you have any recommendations we would
love to hear them just leave a comment
below and let us know what your favorite
spot is yeah we'd love to see you there
so if you're in Indiana you're in Ohio
or if you're in any of the other 40
cities that we're going through this
year head on over to Les is now calm you
can find all the tour dates all the
theater information ticket information
we're looking forward to seeing you soon
will hug you soon
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you were fine
without it
[Music]
every little singing that you got a hand
every little sing me that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without so tear your
eyes
[Music]